[Music]
hello everyone it is Peri back here at
the kia supper suite in Park City and
right now I have the filmmakers behind
Shirley big congratulations to you guys
I saw the movie I heard that the
premiere screening went over extremely
well yesterday are you doing yes it was
awesome feeling good
oh yeah it's a dream this is like you
know getting to screen your movie and
with 2,000 people at the echo Lass's
super high up on the bucket list right
there
so there are some people out there that
probably do not know what Shirley is
about so I must give this question to
you Josephine can you tell us a little
bit about the synopsis sure so Shirley's
about Shirley Jackson the writer it's
inspired by her life it's a fictional
account um this whole film was adapted
from a book a fictional book about
Shirley and her husband Stanley who is
played by Michael Stuhlbarg inviting
this younger couple Oh played by Odessa
young and Logan Lerman into their home
and it sort of has a I guess you could
say Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf II
vibe in terms of the way that the older
couple kind of plays with you know plays
a little cat like Mouse we were joking
it's sort of like the cat putting the
paw on the cockroach and like you know
just like oh yeah I'm gonna let you run
away and then I'm gonna smush your face
and then I'm gonna let you run away love
her then dismiss your face and it's a
little bit that between the older couple
and the younger couple and yeah and but
it's also about this kind of deeper the
concern of a creative artist trying to
make her work in a moment when it wasn't
the easiest moment for a woman to be the
bread she was a breadwinner of her
household in real life so it's about
sort of that sort of the monstrosity of
the creative process and how it can be
very self-destructive and maybe also
destructive to other people that's a
great description I feel like you had so
many different layers of the story right
there's a lot of layers there really are
here and I'm also not gonna get the cat
cockroach thing out of my mind now
something interesting the other day
about the integration themselves which I
thought was kind of interesting you
mention yeah well we you know there's a
lot of Shirley Jackson's stories
involved two female main characters or
like for instance we have always lived
in the cast
in the hunting of Hill House there's
these this like kind of perfect ideal
female character who's great at baking
and keeping the house clean and like
it's just jovial and gets along with
everyone and then there's the main
character of the book who is a
misanthrope and can kind of barely
function in the world and deeply relies
on that other character to sort of stay
happy feel a bit mothered and but but
well left her own devices is just kind
of like waiting to crack open and fall
apart and I think to me Shirley was sort
of writing and I think her biographers
talked about this that she it seems like
she's writing about the two sides of her
herself she was actually an incredible
Baker a mother who wrote a lot about her
experiences mothering but also had a
very dark side a very self-destructive
side and it was also creative genius and
super hilarious
so these two characters in our film we
have this kind of misanthropic Shirley
and this bubbly bright light of this
young woman Rose I think are sort of two
halves of the consciousness that in our
film we sort of are trying to integrate
I've been hearing a lot about how you
kind of find the film and find the
character more and more as the process
goes along so I'm curious for you
Michael what were some of your burning
questions for Josephine after your very
first read of the script and how did
that change as the process went along
gosh I don't remember what my initial
questions were I loved the script Sara
gubbins script and I didn't know
anything about Shirley Jackson but what
I did eventually discover during the
course of making the film was that
initially the the characters were based
on the real Shirley Jackson and Stanley
Edgar Hyman who were married and lived
in Bennington but this script was based
on a fictional novel and that we were
taking that fictional novel and removing
it another step so that that we were
taking what were the real people and
creating fictional circumstances for
them to sort of bustle around in
which was exciting because oftentimes if
you're playing someone who actually
lived you feel a great responsibility to
honor who they were what they went
through to know those things and in this
case it kind of freed us up to play in a
way that I wouldn't have had otherwise
which was delightful I get that vibe
quite a bit from from watching it can
you tell us a little bit about Josephine
as an actor's director and creating that
environment where you feel inclined to
play on set well that was something that
was one of the one of the reasons I was
really excited to work with Josephine
was because she's a an actor and a
performance artist and an editor and a
million other things talking about
integrating all of your identities
together which is so cool
and I've been after trying to explode my
preparation process trying to figure out
for myself other ways to find my way
into things so we explored physical
stuff initially we asked ourselves weird
questions we questioned each other in
terms of who our characters were and
tried to just sort of shake things up a
bit in the beginning and also in the
middle of a scene that was a very
literate literary scene Jo would say
okay throw the language out and just
just do something physical physicalize
this or let's explore another aspect of
what is actually going on here and yeah
just throw the language out of it and I
think that was one of the interesting
experiments and you you the uniqueness
of the marriage between Sara's script
and what Jo brings as an artist is this
explosion of what you see on the page
and an exploration of what's underneath
the words so that was thrilling and I
wanted more of it we didn't have a lot
of time as well but you found a way I
think masterfully to explore that
underground
as well and that comes across I think in
the film is this the first time you've
directed from a script that you didn't
write yes for feature at least yeah what
was that process like and were there any
kind of I don't know unexpected
maybe challenges or freedoms in that
yeah you know in some ways so Sarah
Cummins wrote an incredible script that
it definitely was very dialogue driven
you know it's a film about people you
know sharing their Bliss's and tragedies
I guess and and or creating Bliss's and
tragedies between each other and as a
filmmaker who's I think of my previous
work I've had very little dialogue in my
movies too you would might say and rely
much more on like image and sound and so
a lot of my work was her script was kind
of I mean I spent a lot of time with DES
script itself visualizing and trying to
just see what image felt like it would
help bring what was on the page to life
but truly I think the gift of having
Michael and Lizzie on board I mean
there's such different actors - and
Odessa and Logan was just that everyone
was really I think everyone everyone was
equally excited by the script and
everyone had strong ideas and ways that
they wanted to dig in and what was great
was that I think I just tried to create
or like pushed for enough time to get to
do some rehearsals so we tried to you
know and I really let I mean Michael is
a complete genius so I feel like I got
to really learn from him so much you
know making this film and seeing the way
that he prepares he prepares so deeply
and I mean there was just some of the
most gorgeous moments in the movie came
out of I think your that's deep
preparation that you did because it was
it's just it he created he is someone
who taught me that dialogue can be a
dance and I dance I understand you know
and seeing the way he used dialogue to
move around we have some really
important scenes that happen in the
dinner table the dinner table scene can
be so boring it's four people sitting at
a table you know but but he created a
physicality around that table and and it
it has a movement and a life and I think
so really I think a lot of my work and
what I didn't trying to bring that
script to life was
these guys who really really know what
they're doing have enough time hopefully
to play I mean it was we barely had any
time it always felt like but trying to
create as much as possible time that
that they could explore the space and I
really wanted the actors to get the
chance to put that dialogue in their
bodies and that we would define the
shots based on their choices in terms of
how they wanted to perform so that I
think was important to me in terms of
bringing the script to life is letting
the actors make the big decisions and
like giving ourselves time to say does
it feel like Lizzie wants to be right
next to Michael in this moment or does
she need to be completely across the
room and so that there was a physicality
to the language that was happening as
subtext to the actual language it sounds
like this is a highly collaborative
process between you and your cast so I
am curious during the casting process
like what do you look for in the folks
that you want to bring on board that
makes you think like they're they're
going to bring to my film what I need
from them in that respect well you know
it's funny because I don't know that you
can ever you don't when you cast them
when you don't know their process you
don't really know and and in some ways I
kind of think I probably maybe should
have had more conversations about
process ahead of time you know like to
really and then to dig into we
definitely talked about how did we each
like to prepare but then we got on set
it was kind of like a mash-up of you
know whatever we could accomplish and
everyone bringing their best selves and
also their best techniques I guess to
this to the set but I yeah I don't know
what way you can figure that out I think
we you know I feel like we chose the
actors we chose for this film or you
know or have the delight of having
getting to work with us because we love
their work you know so that was and just
seeing actors who can be like utterly
authentic that you just there's that not
only do you believe them but you're
taken into their world
that's just so special and I think I've
really felt that about really all of our
lead actors that they kind of pull us
into their worlds
I can't wind this conversation down
without asking you to talk about
because I think she is just one of the
best of the best out there and an
up-and-coming star that everybody should
be keeping an eye on right now so having
worked with her what is that special
spark you see in her that maybe just
reinforces what I just said well I'll
say so
sadly Odessa huh we she couldn't make it
she was should a visa she couldn't get
into the u.s. which is such a must be a
blessing to Odessa somewhere but we were
so sad that she didn't make it into the
United States and she really wanted to
be here and I think it would have been
wonderful to have her here because she
is like a magnanimous like you know one
of the stars of this film and she's
stunning in the movie really you know
drives our whole we see the whole story
through her eyes I think the you know
the thing that felt so right about her
the whole time so we're making a period
film about a woman who has a know some
ways a very very conventional role and
is oppressed and that can be something
that we've seen a million times before
you know that that kind of like oh I'm
just the mousy young woman who's being
oppressed by society and we saw it
odessa's audition tape and it just had a
wild like fear Ole Miss to it and we
were like oh that could be rose you know
it was brought something to it that we
didn't even know could be in the
character and then to have that person
the Sphero like you know a woman
desiring to escape you know her body
basically in that role it just gave a
whole layer of depth and dimension to
rose to this you know lead character of
our film that I don't and I don't know
if I mean I feel like Odessa was a gift
from God because she really she's always
just so willing to go all the way yeah
before I go I before we go for you have
to go I can't say enough time things
about Odessa she I had so much fun
working with her on the film before we
leave the topic of the film and I'm
missed her being here to celebrate this
but particularly after seeing the film
seeing how effortlessly she can keep our
attention simply being
present and you can't take your eyes off
her in this movie she's the heart of and
the soul and the spirit behind a large
part of this film she became a she has a
strength 8 that is undeniable and I
can't wait to see all the things that
she does I couldn't agree more
I want to end on that no cuz it's so
beautiful but I also wanted to ask you
guys this other ones I'm very curious
about your take on it two Academy Awards
are coming up if you could add one
category to the lineup what would you
pick and why casting casting directors
who have been so generous
to everybody and are present and helpful
throughout the entire process from the
beginning to the end I know there are
several categories that could be
included but that's a huge part of what
this creative endeavor is about them
having the awareness of what's going out
there in the world to bring new faces
and new ideas to what what what a a
director might envision like having a
conversation about Odessa coming in and
her showing you a different side to who
that character could be and I don't know
about a category but I will speak to
female I wish that there were more
female directors in the directing
category and I feel like Greta Gerwig
and Lulu Wayne should have been
nominated they are they made stunning
movies that are feats of directing there
are directing feats that I think work on
levels that are you know it frustrates
me that just to make it seems too often
to make an Academy award-nominated film
to be nominated for a director you have
to kill people that's devastating and
that rules out most films I think women
are deeply interested in a different
kind of storytelling that's much more
character-driven and and i think that
kind of storytelling to make that like
rocket out of the theater takes so much
subtle and nuanced and so much insight
as a director and I saw that in I mean
many films by women this year but I
think especially you know Lulu Inge and
Greta Gerwig I just wish that they had
been nominate
I couldn't agree more can I ask you one
follow-up to that how do you think we
can start to make steps to changing that
is it about adding more nominations to
the category is it about you know
getting them in front of I is more often
what do you think the key is as I was
because I got into the Academy this year
which was a huge gift I mean I was so
excited I yeah badass I guess I was you
know voting was such a pleasure but it
also made me realize you know and I
don't know the exact numbers of how many
County members there are but I you know
I realized that so many of my female
director friends are working and their
mothers and it was actually a job to try
to see all of the movies to get
nominated and it takes a long time and I
know that I actually was I'm a I just
had a baby this this this fall it was
really hard for me to make the time to
try to see you know a small percentage
of the movies that were nominated or
that were you know shortlisted and and I
think in some ways it's so funny because
I think it's there's what's great is
more female director friends I have are
working now than ever before which is
like thanks God for that that's awesome
and thanks for you know all of the
really awesome studio executives who are
hiring these woman to direct films but I
also think that I was like who are the
people who are sitting at home able to
watch you know like 45 movies in two
weeks you know and I was like what some
people who probably are older maybe
maybe are retired and I think that still
it's gonna I think it's gonna take us a
minute you know for the Academy
membership to catch up to our time you
know and I think they're working so hard
to integrate and to have way more woman
make more people of color in the Academy
but I think I guess I saw one of the
nominations came out I felt like I felt
like I was a certain kind of person who
is still the majority of the voter in
the Academy and I think that's probably
it may just take a few more years of
this very thoughtful work that the
Academy's been doing I think to bring
way more woman and people of color ends
but also you know with the more films
that are getting out there by woman by
people of color is I think the more more
opportunities will have to nominate
those homes and the bigger budgets those
directors get
time today another huge congratulations
to you on the movie to everybody out
there keep an eye out for Shirley also
we have to say a big thanks to Kia we
are at the supper suite in Park City and
we are so grateful to have this
opportunity to talk to you fine folks
about your movies so like and share this
interview before you leave and stay
tuned we're gonna have more from Park
City for you real soon